as he mentioned several areas saw some
snowfall through the overnight hours
bianca holman stopped by one of those
areas fox hill park on the far west
part of town earlier today to show us
how it was looking out there
we rarely get snow here in the valley so
folks were ready to take advantage of it
here at fox hill park there was a large
crowd
ready to enjoy the snow globe experience
here are some pictures and video from
other parts of town in the northwest
valley there was snow
everywhere coating trees covering the
ground the flurries didn't stop
joggers or early morning commuters from
making their way out
cynthia gainey the organizer of the
vegas strong 5k sent us these pictures
they were taken on the 215 between
cheyenne and lone mountain
she says they got up to three inches of
snow we even got pictures from our
friends in perum
drivers having to clear off their
windshield of snow
before heading off and then our
four-legged friends dogs playing in the
white powder
pam and brett haynes and pahrump sent us
pictures of their dog frank
enjoying the early morning snow it's
been really nice i just like
going down the hills and sledding it's
really cool
i've lived in las vegas my whole life it
doesn't snow here often
that mom and daughter we spoke with were
decked out in their snow gear they said
this was their second time
out to the park on this snow day we know
the snow will be melting
soon but be sure to send us your
pictures and video to our facebook page
instagram and twitter reporting from
summerlin bianca holman 8 news now